how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in game is heading back to the
theaters on June 28th less than a week
from now with some new footage Marvel
Studios is President Kevin Feige
officially announced a few days ago that
Avengers in game will be re releasing
into theaters with new scenes that we
did not see before with the first run
and since Kevin Feige announced this we
have a better idea of what we can expect
to see in the re-release of Avengers in
game also if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my Marvel Legends item giveaway I'll be
picking three winners at four hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers now
although Kevin Feige was a little bit
vague in his message he was very clear
on what we can expect in a recent
interview he said it's not an extended
cut but there will be a version going
into theaters with a bit of a marketing
push with a few new things at the end of
the movie now obviously this marketing
push is so Avengers in game has a chance
to be avatar
however Kevin Feige did say that there
will be some new scenes in that same
interview he said if you stay and watch
the movie after the credits there will
be a deleted scene a little tribute and
a few surprises now we have recently
learned that this tribute is of course
to the late Stan Lee this makes perfect
sense obviously and is something that
the fans are sure to enjoy as far as a
few surprises most people are expecting
something in relation to spider-man far
from home maybe an exclusive clip right
before the movie comes out into theaters
and something that'll push people to go
and see spider-man far from home since
it is the last film of phase 3 and as
far as the deleted scene goes most fans
in the community think that we have
figured it out after Avengers in game
came out into the writers the producers
and the directors all revealed that
there were many scenes that didn't make
it into the movie and a few deleted
scenes as well that they cut there are a
lot of deleted scenes that could end up
in the movie for example when Thor says
goodbye to Valkyrie and he makes her the
king of Asgard
the initial scene had him leaning in for
a kiss Valkyrie puts her arm on Thor and
Thor sort of starts to lean in for a
kiss and she goes what are you doing and
he goes oh I thought that the touch and
she's like it's a goodbye tap I'm giving
you so that's a deleted scene that they
could throw in there but doesn't really
have much significance there's another
deleted scene in the final battle where
the fighting kind of style
and all of the heroes sort of come
together in the middle and all start
asking what are we doing well I'm gonna
do this and I'm gonna do this but they
decided to cut that as well but again
the directors and the writers said that
it didn't really flow well so it's
probably not that seen either and you
have to realize that they're going to be
showing us this after the credits so it
has to make sense after the movie and
what makes sense is Tony Stark in the
soul world with his adult daughter
Morgan Stark Catherine Langford was
originally in the movie and like I said
they filmed a scene with Tony Stark and
Morgan Stark that was exactly like the
scene where Thanos sees Gamora after he
snaps after Tony snapped he goes to this
metaphysical world where he sees his
adult daughter of Morgan Stark in this
world she tells him that she forgives
him but they ultimately decided to cut
the scene because they felt like people
wouldn't have a big enough of an
emotional connection to the adult
version of Morgan Stark but this scene
makes the most sense and is what we'll
probably see for the new post-credit
scene of avengers endgame so be sure to
comment with what you think about this
scene with Tony Stark and his adult
daughter Morgan Stark possibly being the
new post-credits scene for avengers
endgame and don't forget to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
you